that's right there's little icons in my
text messages and I did this without the
hacking or jailbreaking my iPhone it's
extremely easy to use so all you have to
do is download this 99-cent app is
called frosty place now once you have it
downloaded and installed click on it so
you launch this up and it's like a
Chinese RSS news Macintosh feed site so
check it out there's all of these
entries that unless you can read
Japanese you probably can't read it
so the most important thing that you
have to do is make sure you click on one
of these articles or entries to get this
activated so there we go
I clicked on one of the stories now I'm
heading right back home to the settings
so click on settings then you want to
scroll down to general and then from
there scroll to international and this
will take you into the keyboards click
keyboards scroll through here until you
find Japanese click Japanese and you'll
get that emoji emoji option that you
want to click to on and that is it
head into your text messages and you'll
have the normal keyboard like always but
click that little world icon and it'll
take you into this beautiful selection
of tons and tons of little icons for
your iPhone it's amazing
check it out leave me a comment if you
get it to work let me know if you have
any other questions and I have an entire
list of step-by-step directions on my
blog I justing comm check it out anyway
thanks for watching please subscribe and
I love you